-I want to talk to you more
about "Avengers: Endgame,"
but since you've been proven
that you can't be trusted...
-What is this?
-...we're gonna hook you up
to a lie detector.
-Oh, come on.
-It's the only way.
Here we go right here.
Now let's get you
strapped in here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm really going for it.
I'm not kidding.
-Come on, man.
-This is real.
This is the real deal.
-That's not cool.
-This is real deal.
Let's try it.
-This is on TV, man.
-No, this is all different inks
and everything.
This is like real deal.
-Oh, Jimmy.
-Hold on. Get this in here.
No, trust me.
-We can cut this, right?
-No, we did this in rehearsal,
and it's real deal.
-All right, man.
-All right, here we go.
Yeah, all right, good.
-Wow, that's --
-Is it tight?
There you go.
No, yeah, this is perfect here.
Let me see your face.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, good.
That's perfect.
All right, yep.
-Oh, yeah.
-All right.
Now, it's comfortable, right?
-It's like the '60s.
-Yeah, it's not that bad.
-It's like "Scanners."
-Okay, here we go.
-All right.
-Now, is there one more piece?
Oh, there's one more piece
right here.
-What's that?
-All right, here we go.
You got to put your fingers
in here.
-Okay, great.
-No, no, not the ring.
I don't want to electrocute you.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Look, already, it's reacting.
Already it's kind of working.
Wait.
-What kind of questions
are you gonna ask me?
-No, look, this is fun!
[ Laughter ]
Thank you so much
for coming back to the show.
This is great.
Now look.
[ Laughter ]
Here's how this works.
If you're lying
or get nervous at all --
okay? --
-What's gonna happen?
-...this red light
will start blinking, and these
needles will move really fast.
Here's where --
The machine --
We just have to calibrate it
really quickly, okay?
-I don't want
to get fired again.
-No, no.
You won't, you won't, you won't.
Ready?
Here we go.
Just tell the truth
for right now, ready?
Is your name Mark Ruffalo?
-Yes.
-Okay.
-It's working.
-Are you sitting in a chair?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, that's good.
Now lie to me
just so we can see what it does.
-Lie?
-Yeah, are you -- yeah.
It's hard.
-Are you currently dressed
like a tiny leprechaun?
-Yes.
[ Needle scratching quickly ]
-All right. See that?
So, it is working.
Okay, good.
-Oh, come on, Jimmy.
-Now, here we go.
I have a few simple
"Avengers" questions.
Is the Hulk secretly
a shape-shifting alien
known as a Skrull?
-What?! No, Jimmy,
I can't answer that, man!
[ Needle scratching quickly ]
-That's a lie.
Are there any hidden clues
in the latest "Avengers" trailer
that no one has figured out yet?
-Not that I'm aware of.
[ Needle scratching quickly ]
[ Laughter ]
This is B.S.!
-No, look at it!
You're still lying!
You're still lying.
This is actually real.
[ Laughter ]
Do Bruce Banner and Black Widow
finally get together
romantically in the new movie?
[ Needle scratching quickly ]
-Jimmy, I can't answer that!
[ Cheers and applause ]
No!
-Come on, dude!
I'm gonna take that
as something.
Okay. Uh.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, this is a good one.
-No, no.
-Is Don Cheadle sexier than you?
-Yes. Yes.
Yes!
[ Laughter and applause ]
I got one right!
-No, stop blinking.
-All right.
Let me just key in here.
♪♪
I love him.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you like the way
your action figure looks?
-I love him!
-You love him? Okay.
-He's the best.
-Okay.
Have you ever
played with yourself?
[ Laughter ]
Be honest.
-No.
[ Needle scratching quickly ]
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Oh, I had to ask that.
All right.
-All right.
Ow!
This thing shocked me.
-I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
It's the last one.
-That's Marvel, man.
-They'll do it.
-They shocked me.
All right, all right.
-Final question -- is everyone
who disappeared in the Snap
from Thanos actually gone,
or is there any way
that they can come back?
-You know what, Jimmy?
I'm outta here.
-Whoa!
Mark Ruffalo, everybody!
Check him out
in "The Avengers: Endgame"
on April 26th!
I hope!